i'm lara van camper i'm working as a
head of sector in trade defense
instruments hey how are you are you
relaxed no this is not a little bit
excessive so my name is wolfgrambula i
am
i work with the european commission in
director of hg
[Music]
what does trade defence mean
it means that you make sure that people
play by the rules and where you cannot
ensure that through negotiation
through dialogue
you must be able to take autonomous
measures in order to level the playing
field
we are not against imports because they
are cheap that is not our issue we are
we are trying to act against or we are
acting against imports that are dumped
or subsidized
[Music]
the anti-dumping instrument looks at
dumped imports and the definition of
dumping is or a product is dumped
if if an exporter sells this product in
a foreign market below the cost of
production in significant quantities or
if the exporter sells its product at a
price which is lower than the higher
than the whole market price
[Music]
we cannot live without production in
europe we cannot put all the production
in another country today i think all the
people understand the benefits of these
anti-damping measures
my name is marcel souza from mat ceramic
from portugal
we are a tableware ceramic factory we
employ more than 500 workers we export
all our production our main market is
the european market
in 2005
we have a new competition from china
we lose sales we lose the market share
the unfair competition from china was
not possible for us
and in 2007 we decided to make
anti-damping process in 2012
we present the case to the commission it
was after the measures
we
win again the market share and the
chinese reduce the market share so
this kind of police
have a huge impact
in the positive or in in the negative
way in 2005 it was a negative way in
2013 it was in a positive way
we've seen that there are especially
state capitalist systems
that tend to
subsidize their industries
leading to distortions of competition to
global over capacity which is to the
detriment of everyone
anti-subsidy measures are there to level
that playing field
streaming
these investigations are more difficult
because you need also the cooperation of
a government of a third country
and you need to have a lot of details
and a lot of idea about policies that
are in place while a dumping
investigation is quite
clean and quite economic a product is
subsidized if it benefits from a
financial contribution by the government
if that financial contribution gives a
benefit to the company and if a
financial contribution is specific if a
government for instance gives land to a
company or or creates a motorway
extension to it for a dive specifically
for a company it would be specific
a safeguard measure is there in order to
adjust to a new situation and this new
situation results from a sudden sharp
increase of imports
that harms the industry and that is
probably not going away and so a
safeguard measure is there to to give
the industry in the important country a
bit of briefing space a bit of space to
adjust
so that they can later on function
without any protection in the new
circumstances
[Music]
trade defense is essential because only
if you are able to say
i have the tools to prevent openness
from being abused
will you be able to maintain the
openness we depend on and which we want
[Music]
you